[Music]
in meat is murder news submitted by the
Irishman the top of the mornin to you
know yeah you should you try scary going
by your spot hi y'all they already been
Irish vegans huh are they a bunch of
Irish for vegans is that one no although
that would be an entertaining [ __ ] movie
I don't know I just don't know how that
one looks that's why I want to watch it
why are you paying out police say a
woman stabbed another in a belief that
she was wearing fur so authorities say a
woman stabbed another woman and know how
Church for wearing fur yeah what's crazy
what's [ __ ] crazier about this is
happening how do you like it yeah yeah
but some Meredith Lowell 35 is being
held on a million dollar bond after
attacking when somebody in a yeah that
the murder on church grounds yeah but
you it's high but you once you hear
about this lady you're like that makes a
lot of sense actually
so make sense about the crazy lady or
about the lady who got stabbed no the
crazy lady why her bond is so high aside
from the attempt robably escalation
physician murder yeah exactly so then
first of all this this is the leader
after he's got she's got the crazy eyes
Jimmy is cut off in the picture it's
still there was like [ __ ] you know what
if she's bald on top maybe that's why
she's envious of her she could use a
little bit on the top there he said yeah
so apparently she was the one of the
other lady who was dropping off her kids
at this church to in a be in a day care
or whatever they're just this lady when
stabbed her in the abdomen and then
stabbed her in the arm all these other I
don't think so stabbed twice in the arm
and once in the abdomen I don't think
she died though victim in brought
children yeah so she was a victim but
she fortunately did not die from this so
then everybody
yeah like tackled her and then they
always sounds really intense with the
word stab you know because it would be
like Oh a bunch of stabs whatever but
they also count it like if it just
slashes to right dad yeah that's still a
pretty traumatic yeah I know but cuz I
know I think about a stabbing Adam
abdomen it's like going through your
body lie still
like how did they survive it still think
estab is like yeah lemme you can get
relatively Queen laceration it still
counts right if it just like I don't
know how they do they report that I
don't know what the exact wording is but
yeah I mean I can imagine her getting
stabbed in the arm and then also getting
stabbed in the stomach like that's
pretty that's to me is pretty believable
but yeah this isn't the first [ __ ]
time she's like apparently yeah or no
attack somebody for wearing fur my
question is is was it actually for all
of it like a faux fur the in the article
they don't know what this most recent
one they don't know if it was if she was
actually wearing fair enough this lady
just thought she was wearing fur so but
she was arrested a year ago on suspicion
of attacking someone she believed was
wearing for a she so she punched and
then tried to cut a woman wearing a
jacket with fake fur on the hood with a
serrated blade of a Swiss Army knife the
jacket was gashed a police photo show
the woman was not cut so she was lucky
and she didn't get cut but she was
indicted John Rowan now a felony felony
assault felonious felon US yeah alone
yes the case is pending and then she and
then on top of this in March she was
indicted in federal court after other
authorities said she posted on Facebook
saying she she wanted to hire a hitman
to kill someone wearing fur any of you
guys guys know one or are looking for a
hitman I need someone to paint houses so
and then so she was talking about good
references I don't know Ryan
I think it did Irishman reference so she
was with so she went to Germany she
would be willing to pay between eight
hundred thirty dollars and eight hundred
fifty dollars between that range of 8:30
to 8:50 and she's willing to pay yeah
that was her price range anywhere
between
for a hit thousand dollars it's not
worth it be like I'm willing to pay like
minimum wage but she was apparently
contacted by an undercover FBI agent
because here's a quick tip for any guys
thinking about posting [ __ ] on Facebook
if you're gonna ask her something
illegal on Facebook specifically getting
someone killed nine times out of ten the
person that's gonna contact you is
probably in the with the FBI so just
quick tip I would love to see that
expand so they doing that no what'd she
sing she'll look out for all the crazies
on Facebook then yeah exactly exactly
there's other sites for that
anyway it's Twitter yeah Twitter can you
list them for us please right yeah so
she asked that the person be killed with
a gun or a knife at the Cleveland
Heights library and that she planned to
be there when the murder was carried out
for some you need to see it enjoy it and
bask in the blood why does she have a
bond even exactly and she told the agent
she want to set up an animal rights
militia and specified the victim of the
library should it be at least twelve
should be at least twelve years old and
at least four feet tall I don't know why
she was like also trying to go after
children that's cuz she tells her cut
off she was like what if they're 12 they
can make their own decision he's 12
years old
she was arrested in February she's like
if you can go to juvie you can be
martyred but you know what's [ __ ]
crazy is the way that this story ends it
says those charges were dropped in
January 2013 when it was determined she
could not be rehabilitated to competency
court records oh so they don't have
you're so crazy that we can't
rehabilitate you okay bye click back out
what there you go you're free you're
free to go you know you would think the
idea that it's like okay we need to keep
you exactly like please put this person
in a place where she can't hurt other
people or I'm like I get the whole like
you know prisons are supposed to be like
rehabilitation in a sense but that's why
you have other things for that like
mental asylum exactly so I'm just like
yo so the basically the court said that
she's so crazy we can't fix her so we're
just gonna see what happens people make
those decisions you're like how how do
you have a job well had to be in court
though right it had to be a court case
exactly like
cleared multiple people right like
whenever the [ __ ] like this happens like
a lot of people were like that makes
sense yeah but it's just crazy to me
that like it was like yo this is like a
lot of like very clear sign this person
is like violent like you know and
there's so many felonies that like she
had like already like stacked yet so I
was like what the [ __ ] like how is this
just a thing yeah but I mean do you know
any but like you do is know anybody
that's like super into like animal
rights to the fight to the point that
they'll like I don't personally know
anybody like that well I know people who
are extremists like I'll see on Facebook
too and that's the place where you find
extremists yeah yeah right and like I am
FBI agent yeah I keep them around
not in my life where I can fire well not
just that I'm like I don't want to
forget you exist I want to feel like
this is a fairy tale world where there
isn't people where they aren't evil yeah
like some of them aren't that crazy but
you're doing a little bit much little
bit crazier I call it crazy I don't know
if you would murder me but you might
murder somebody yeah well what if that
person might be you because it's like Oh
matter of like if they're an extremist
it's just a matter of being able to
dislike it's like sure they won't met
like murder you but if you disagree with
them on the right thing yeah I mean like
when that day comes and I see a facebook
status going hey can I hire hit men for
three hundred and forty dollars
yeah I got your price dropped again 132
like you're like born in 30 I think
that's all my life is yeah so like if I
see that see that's another reason to
keep them around on Facebook I'm gonna
be like I'm gonna call the police now
I'm available for work I'm out of a job
right now and I would
a little bit of misses coming around I
could buy so many presents yeah goodbye
a new guy yeah I could write that off in
my taxes I think right it's a work item
you guys like wearing jackets that have
fur like the real fur it could be like
the faux fur but you know that look I
want some I looked at one this weekend
and I was like Marian I want this she
was like you have a jacket I went that's
true yeah I didn't buy it I ran into the
same I enjoyed the more like sleek
looking like that's puffy heads like
this one was like a snow jacket and I
could I was like a lie could imagine
being in snow edge I was like that's
cute as [ __ ] but then Marian was like
you already have it's no jacket you
bought last year so no I didn't and you
were like you make a good point
yeah legs even a right behind Ryan
mm-hmm
I'd wear that over faux fur any day I'm
not like so into those jackets mainly
just because when you wash it I don't
know maybe you don't wash it I don't get
dry cleaned
okay well look Matt like so many years
of having like little stuffed animals
that have like very similar faux fur
like that and they've gone into the wash
because my mom likes to put in the wash
and when she puts it in the dryer and it
comes out it's all curly and joint
stuffed animal dog that I still have
today since I was a little kid it's
always - yeah like tell bumping a pillow
yeah exactly but yeah but anyway it's
like wearing those jackets it's very
Daddy key to me when I take it off and I
touch something I'm like that yeah I
think it's a dying trend I mean you see
all these high-end brands getting
headlines that they're gonna stop you
for dying Trey what's something really
thanks for your framing because right
now the trend is in to have a big old
fur jacket yeah that's why my people
like this it's like sheets it's like
they focus I don't know she's obviously
delusional but it's also like you gotta
focus on dude 10 years ago for you in 15
years ago everybody is still getting
will real fur yeah yeah look at like the
hoodie Paulette the positives I guess oh
yeah situation it's a slow progression
the fashion is tonight like I think I
think you made sense when that was like
a necessity when they didn't have access
to materials that work
the same way that fer did yeah I feel
like that's that's the main thing a lot
of times now like my attitude towards
fur or me or whatever I'm like it's not
a necessity so I'm gonna try not to do
it wherever possible I feel a little bit
differently about me I feel a little bit
differently I'm like I'll still eat the
meat by a chalk cut back because I know
it's not required in my diet anymore
these days so I try to eat less of it
wherever I can but then have a nice
steak whenever I want to or sushi or
whatever but like if I'm not having it
what are you shooting of course you'd
have that see yeah yeah right wait you
put it on your face it's a perfect
likeness he's usually pretty good about
listening to when we stop talking
outside yeah yeah what a man you got
here safely we're guys talk about
Devon's not here yet well we're talking
about faux fur Oh poker I'm coming okay
we're